on va parler à présent agriculture avec
la finale régionale d'un concours je ne
connaissais pas les ovmpiades c'est un
concours régional de jeunes bergers très
bien prononcé Aurélien toute la journée
ces jeunes bergers et bergères ont
concouru pour décrocher une place en
finale nationale au Salon de
l'Agriculture de Paris le mois prochain
au programme une série d'épreuves
pratiques où ils ont dû reproduire les
gestes quotidiens d'un éleveur de brebis
coup des onglons tri des bêtes les EOS
sculé en tout une quarantaine de jeunes
ont tout donné pour décrocher le
précieux sésame Léa Turquier était sur
place
paupière oreilles et dentition tout est
passé au crible abigel récolte des
indices pour évaluer l'état de santé de
cette brebie ça s'est plutôt bien passé
la brebie elle est ni trop malade ni
parfaite non plus mais il y a deux trois
deux trois défauts mais sinon c'est
c'est plutôt bien une épreuve technique
Allian maîtrise des gestes et
connaissance des ins la difficulté pour
les candidats c'est surtout en fait de
nous parler en même temps qu'ils font
l'activité et surtout de de Paser en
fait d'aller plus loin dans le l'analyse
par exemple il voit la troisème paupière
qui est rose mais il nous explique pas à
côté par exemple qu'il existe la jaune
la rouge et pour quelle raison de
l'autre côté de la bergerie Alicia
mesure l'engraissement des
agneaux7 une tâche pas forcément
évidente car chronométrée elle doit en
examiner trois en moins de 3 minutes 30
un défi relevé au la main pour set
habitué du concours j'ai déjà participé
l'année dernière ça m'a beaucoup plu et
j'ai ressenté cette année pour voir si
je pouvait faire mieux que l'année
dernière et c'est toujours un plaisir de
participer à différentes activités
proposé autour des in quoi 34 jeunes
s'affrontent pour ces sélections
régionales des ovimpiades deux d'entre
eux partiront ensuite à Paris
représenter la région centreevde Loire
lors du concours national du meilleur
jeune berger de France 2024 on est une
région où il y a de l'ovin il y a des
RAC au vines on vair le bérichon du Cher
le bérichon de lindr la solot euh et euh
forcément on a envie que du coup euh cas
se perdure sur notre territoire que les
éleveurs restent en place et ça permet
aussi de de faire découvrir cette
filière à des jeunes euh qui arrivent
dans le milieu la finale nationale se
tiendra le 24 février prochain pour
l'ouverture du Salon de l'Agriculture à
Paris